oh
stand on top
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm sean evans and you're
watching hot ones it's the show with hot
questions and even hotter wings and
today by popular demand i'm joined by
terry crews you know him from his many
films tv shows and of course you can
catch him on fox's award-winning hit
show brooklyn nine-nine now in its fifth
season terry welcome to the show how are
you doing good terry how are you i'm
good i'm hungry you're not fast every
day so
it's we waited till two o'clock it's now
two we can officially eat we can do it
how are you with hot food i've had some
really hot stuff before and didn't die
so i'm okay are you ready to get it
going i'm ready
[Music]
all right so this first one is valentina
all right here we go
[Music]
so i want to start by talking about an
interesting time in your life the
purgatory between when your nfl career
ended and before the hollywood dream
began because as i understand it you
were doing temp jobs you were sweeping
factory floors and then especially
interesting to me
working as a part of ice cube security
detail i was location security so i
would do a bunch of different movies it
just so happened i was on next friday
because i was like the biggest guy so
they would assign me right outside his
trailer and he parked in the whole thing
and i'm like hey mr cube and he was like
yeah what's up you know it was really
like dismissive and
and the whole thing and i just took care
of business i mean i i really wanted to
be
you know a good security guard i didn't
want to be like here's my demo tape here
i want to be an actor
because i wasn't even into that at the
time what was wow was that once i was an
extra in training day
that's when he was like hey that's the
dude that was out there well you know
doing security and the whole thing and
then i got my opportunity for friday
after next and dude it change our lives
forever and it's interesting too how in
this business it can come full circle
that way you know at one point you're
just giving a little head nod to cube
and then the next time he's putting you
in the movie exactly exactly because i
wanted to get in the business so
[Music]
all right
so you're renaissance man with a resume
to match but i think the fans will kill
me if i didn't focus on brooklyn
nine-nine for a wing what's the origin
story of the yogurt thing it's funny
because once we started filming
you know i would always eat yogurt you
know it was one of the things and some
writer was watching and picking it up
and they felt what is a really healthy
thing that terry jeffords would love you
know like yogurt and it just became this
iconic thing i'm still waiting for my
big big giant deal
yogurt
who's been your favorite cameo on the
show and why is it marshawn lynch
marshawn was great though he was really
really good i think eva longoria was
awesome eve has always been a friend and
she killed it who's the set clown who's
the funniest off-camera it's weird
because andy's a very serious guy you
know he's got he calculates his comedy
you know he's always like that but
chelsea peretti is hilarious all the
time we laugh non-stop she is the life
of the party
and i truly think she's probably one of
the funniest people tv has ever seen
mm-hmm i like fortnite
come on bro
can you talk to me how you went from not
knowing a damn thing about computers to
all of a sudden building a custom
state-of-the-art gaming pc with your son
wow wow
that right there
was really cool i remember watching my
son playing video games playing on a
computer and i was like what you playing
he was like i'm not playing that you
know what okay what are you doing he's
like i'm watching
excuse me i was like what and i found
out he was actually watching people play
and i was like oh this is weird i didn't
understand what was happening and i said
i've got to find a way to connect with
his world because one thing i remember
is that my father never wanted to come
connect with what i was doing like i was
like hey dad check this out and he'd be
like i'm busy you know you're like
and i'll never forget how that felt and
i said i'm gonna get into what he's all
about but once i played battlefield i
saw they had these tower computers and
they were playing with keyboards and
mouses i was like oh wait i didn't even
know about you and i remember they were
like you got to build it that makes it
better you know i was like really
like i was like there's nobody that can
pay and all that but then i said no this
is what me and my son
can do together it's the new ham radio
all of a sudden things started to make
sense the more you stay around and
you're like oh that goes in there and
the sound card goes look goes right here
oh and the graphics card is spinning
it's fitting and it was so satisfying
and man it changed my life forever
changed my life and it's interesting
because you know i think that the video
game obsession it freaks a lot of
parents out when they see their kids
getting into it but as somebody who went
through that experience how did it
change your perspective as a parent when
it comes to video games well i mean i
saw the potential i saw how beautiful
that whole thing is it's no different
than reading comic books
and i thought what a beautiful thing
it's beautiful i'm all choked up and
it's not the wigs
the queen the crown
got a picture of a leopard on it oh my
damn
so i want to talk to you about your nfl
career because as a hard knocks fan i'm
fascinated by the sort of bottom of the
roster dog-eat-dog competition that goes
on and you're someone who experienced
that with a handful of teams and i know
that it's a very tough business at what
point did you feel most chewed up and
spit out wow it had to be
it was 1997.
i got a try out with the 49ers and uh
they treated me so bad i mean they
treated me like i was dirt he was
working me out like he was mad and he
had to be out there it was just a
psychological mess i was a little
farther away from him than i am with you
and he threw the ball at me and i put my
hand up and
my finger was like an l
it totally
went sideways and i snapped it back and
i was like well
what are you doing you know he was like
come on come on let's get the workout
good i was like
i'm done and i remember coming home to
my wife and i said
never again that was never again i was i
was so done
this is your label mm-hmm
it's tasty
very tasty thank you terry i appreciate
that oh a lot of times they just got
heat but this one got a taste
all right all right so we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that gram we do a deep dive on
our guests instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context oh my
god so i'll show you the picture and
then if you could just tell me the
bigger story does that sound good that's
good that hit me all right terrier
that's interesting this is a great show
you're having fun terry i'm having fun
now tell me afterwards if you had a good
time
first things first yeah
let me say lint academy very aggressive
pose for the short shorts era oh my gosh
it was a magical idea because you know
you got to know
i had the george girvin iceman poster in
my room and he was sitting on this block
of ice with two basketballs and i was
like dude i need like my own george
gervin posters thing and it was really
bad i didn't even lotion my knees dog
oh my god look at how dusty the knee is
up next
you're on horseback the horse is it your
favorite animal i hear it's your
favorite animal first of all i love
horses when i was a young man
i used to always want to rivals growing
up in flint michigan they were like oh
man man the horse is going to kill you
man the horse gonna step on your head
dog it's gonna be horrible and then you
finally go yeah yeah that's kind of
stupid yeah uh i shouldn't i wanna ride
horses finally went to riot horses and
learned how to do a gal up and uh
the best time let me tell you it was the
best time i was like damn it don't ever
let anybody talk you out of what you
want to do
and they were all wrong terry you could
have gone your whole life without
knowing the joy of riding a horse in the
sunset yeah and this is me on my day off
here you are with the iron yeah the iron
addict c.t fletcher c.t fletcher we got
a background that's the same we both had
major major issues with our fathers and
my father was very abusive
very very i mean one of my earliest
memories is uh
him you know basically hitting my mom in
the face when i was five years old you
know what i mean and that made me want
to live because you feel like oh my god
if he's hitting her
what's he gonna do to me
my whole life i was totally obsessed
with being strong psychologically
through a lot of therapy you learn that
you're trying to protect yourself i
remember i got beat up a couple times in
high school i said that never happened
again you know and you had to fight to
get into school it was really not like i
want to go to class you ain't going too
good you ain't going nowhere [ __ ]
you're like oh
you know and man i said no not me i'm
going to survive and we're kindred
spirits man that's my man
[Music]
too serious no no no okay because i'm
this is not deep now man that's what we
want that's what the wings do the hot
sauce
they bring out the fire they forgot that
yeah
[Music]
i'll say that right now my man terry
thank you very much
so you can't get pecs like those without
having some discipline in your diet but
i know that on the cheat days you like
to throw down in the kitchen do you have
any cheat day kitchen hacks
i make a color bread pudding
with orange butter sauce take french
bread you let it get about a day old and
i mean literally you want to have a
little crunch on it slice it up you put
some raisins on top you pour like a cup
of butter on the fattest butter you can
find okay make sure it gets all into the
bread and the whole deal then you blend
up about six eggs and some milk and some
sugar and some spices like some cinnamon
and nutmeg i love it and then you blend
it and makes this really big cream and
then put that in there blend it up like
crazy pour it over the sliced bread let
it soak i let that sucker soak until all
the bread is just engorged and full and
make sure you pat it all down and
raisins are all in there bake that
sucker for about 45 50 minutes then i
make some orange butter sauce which is
more butter more butter
with some sugar and about a couple
tablespoons of orange juice to give it a
little twang and then you pour that
sugary mixture over there what it
basically is is a glazed donut
in a pan and now you will be in a carb
coma it's like
you know
it's it's just a major crash because you
you get this energy that just goes
the carbs just run through your system
oh man the walking dead no
[Music]
i look like that guy right there like
there's a guy on the bottle
oh this hurts
i'll take a big bite too
i'm getting serious over here
oh man
[Music]
oh
[Music]
not tasting good
but it's hot
so despite your grueling shoot schedule
i've heard you say that you work out up
to two hours per day yes what something
that was easy for you in the weight room
at 25 that's now kicking your ass as you
approach 50. you know i used to be able
to like have a
90 second you know then you hit it and
do two or three things at the same time
run the gauntlet now i'm like five
minutes i'm good you know i gotta give
you five ten minutes you know between
sets get those lungs back and it's like
i gotta come back
i thought what are the fitness politics
like when you do a movie like the
expendables is the craft service all
protein shakes and sweet potatoes do
they put a gold gym on the lot you know
we don't work out together just because
it's too
you know the challenge is too deep what
was wild is um
i i
it's the competition and you gotta get
those kinds of dogs in there but i i
don't like to compete i don't believe in
competing but
it's inevitable you know and you'll do
something and you'll hurt yourself just
because you're trying to keep up with
people you know i have to be very
careful who i work out with because they
draw you in
and you want to be this and then all of
a sudden your pec is like popping ah you
know you're in the hospital you know
i've seen it happen too many times
[Music]
[Applause]
oh man yeah
oh
it's not yeah yeah there are some
consequences to the bomb oh
whoa
i'm going milk
it's okay it's okay no shame in that
so everyone knows terry crews the actor
terry crews the football player but some
fans might be surprised to know that you
had an art scholarship mixed in with
that athletic full ride at western
michigan is it true that you used to
moonlight by painting portraits for your
nfl teammates making five thousand
dollars a pop that's exactly what i did
i used to go back in the locker room
after i got cut
and i remember because that was my only
way to survive
oh and they
oh
and they would literally be like
man you're pretty good
i was like oh thank you oh man i'm
getting lightheaded yeah
oh man and they would say you're pretty
good
and usually football players are pretty
egotistical yeah they probably like this
yeah yeah man i could put a picture of
you over a city and
you know you put this over imagine this
over your mouthpiece and you will love
it
and they were like oh yeah we'll do it
and
and i really i did a lot of that that's
how i said bye
all right careful around your eyes terry
oh yeah
what's the last thing you drew or
painted
well uh i actually did a pilot with andy
sandberg about a show that i'm doing
called culinary where i draw
celebrities as i interview them kind of
like hot ones
[Laughter]
oh man where are you at terry okay okay
i'm ready to move all right oh my god
okay
okay how much more we got
listen you get high off this [ __ ] yeah
yeah for sure that's that's how this
show exists i don't i don't care about
the youtube views i'm just chasing the
dragons
is some like
my voice is changing yeah oh you gotta
turn it into three people man
oh my god
[Music]
oh
stand on top
oh
yes so we've had a lot of talented
actors with range on this show but i'm
going to be real with you your imdb page
there's just something different about
it it's magnificent i want to bounce
rolls off of you and i want you to tell
me which one was the most underrated
does that sound good
team money brawling mma fighters and a
hamster wheel on battle dome yes the
troll spencer belting out a thousand
miles in white chicks president camacho
busting shot from the presidential deus
and idiocracy
president camacho was underrated
because no one
it was a bomb
the movie did not work
no one saw it
and then years later
years later people caught it
oh my god i was hurt and then your
characters they tend to be insanely
quotable
what is the terry cruzism that gets
yelled at you most often in airports
power
everybody does that and then another one
is uh remember this [ __ ] at christmas
from the expendables the first one oh my
god
so
all right terry here's a
napkin
how you doing my man it's not man
all right terry i'm gonna oscar with
this one
let me do this i love all my people out
there love you all
dude i'm light-headed i can't i don't
know how you walk out here
[Music]
one more wing to go and this one is the
last dab we call it the last dab because
it's tradition around here to put a
little extra on the last wing you don't
have to if you don't want to okay
it's okay don't go it's okay it's okay
terry you don't have to well yes but
that's going there damn it
what a comeback story
terry
be careful though
it's good that's good that's good that's
good
oh i hate you
remember how much fun you were having
around to explain that grammar yeah i
know my eyes can't open why don't why
can't i open my eyes
oh my god
you're right my man i'm good man you're
doing good you're doing great you're
doing great terry
i survived the nfl i can do this
all right
goodbye goodbye terry
[Music]
oh
oh man
dude why did i sign up for this man it
is always amazing to me it is always
amazing to me it baffles me i scratch my
head but i'm very grateful it's been a
revolving door i don't know how oh man
am i here find me my man you see me you
catching me oh man i feel like steve
jobs in the 70s
trip about to come up with a crazy app
after this
all right terry so whether it's walking
a red carpet or eating the wings of
death you're very comfortable in the
spotlight but it seems to me
like you're most at home when you're
barking into your phone from the
driver's seat of your car yes letting
your followers know that they have one
more set in them so now that the wings
have kicked into your empty stomach the
last dab settling into your soul what's
the terry crew's advice for the fans out
there that just keep hitting the snooze
button there's a quote by ralph waldo
emerson that i have used
for my life
and the biggest thing ever is that god
will not have his work
made manifest by cowards love it dude
when you realize and internalize that
that nothing on this earth
now that doesn't mean not being scared
what it means is doing it anyway taking
that last bite of that win
anyway
being willing to let people see you snap
in front of everybody
ah
what [ __ ]
terry i have chills going down my spine
i'm not sure if they're the words or if
it's the death sauce but either way i
feel great and looking at you i can tell
that you feel great too terry crews i
love you too terry this is a spiritual
experience it was a climb up the
mountain together
and now i just want to roll out the red
carpet for you and my man i did it this
camera this camera or this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life dude i got
i got brooklyn nine-nine happening
season five man we made it dude i am one
of the only few people to have three
consecutive scripted shows go past 100
episodes to be syndicated let me tell
you something when you work you learn
you grow i love you all man watch
brooklyn 999 please i went through this
for your ass
oh my god i love you dude
dude i need your phone number because
now we're friends forever
oh my god dude i'm really dizzy hello
hot ones fans it's shawn evans new outro
same message if you like what you saw
throw us a bone maybe please it is dog
eat dog here on the youtube streets hit
that subscribe button knowing that you
subscribed it is seriously the only
thing that gets me out of bed in the
morning thank you very much hot ones
fans i love you